well it goes back I think to the the
epistemological problem that I think we
face as creatures in our in our world so
I think one question I think it's always
useful to ask in political context is if
I am so sure I'm right how come she's so
sure she's right too if it's obvious
what to me what the answer is if the
answer is obvious why isn't it obvious
to the other person and I think just
that sort of turn taking standing in the
other man's moccasins walking in the
other man's moccasins kind of thing of
saying well I'm so sure I'm right about
this and yet here are these other people
who don't think when I think how is that
are they just fools or irrational or is
there some part of reality that's hidden
from them or could it be that I ought to
reflect more carefully on on what I
think and listen a bit more to what they
have to say so that's a kind of meta
quite as you'd expect from a philosopher
it's nada not it's not it's a question
you asked me to a question about
questions it's an answer about answers
it's an answer about questions about
questions but I think that it is it is a
it is a useful perspective to adopt
given the conflicts that we have in the
world today about many important matters